veamos si podemos sacar la derivada con
respecto a x de la raíz cuarta de x
cúbica más 4x cuadrada más 7 y al
principio podrías decir muy bien como
saco la derivada de la raíz cuarta de
algo parece que tengo una función
compuesta estoy sacando la raíz cuarta
de otra expresión y tendré razón si
estás lidiando con una función compuesta
la regla de la cadena debe ser tu foco
de atención pero primero simplemente
vamos a hacer esta raíz cuarta un poco
más manejable recordando que la podemos
ver como un exponente fraccional así que
esta misma cosa que tengo aquí va a ser
exactamente igual que tomarme la
derivada con respecto a x
y bueno en lugar de poner la raíz cuarta
voy a poner x kubica
x ubican más 4 x cuadrada más 7
todo esto elevado a la potencia un
cuarto y quiero la derivada de esto que
tengo aquí bueno como dije hace unos
segundos lo que podemos usar es la idea
de que ésta es una función compuesta que
te parece si llamamos a todo esto a todo
esto
primero como no sé cómo de equis o de
equis y así vamos a poder encontrar su
derivada de una manera más sencilla
porque aquí tengo a de x elevado la
potencia un cuarto así que la manera en
la que vamos a sacar esta derivada es
primero sacando la derivada de estos de
de x elevado a la 14 podríamos verlo
como la derivada de la función externa
con respecto a de x y después vamos a
multiplicarlo por la derivada de 1 con
respecto a
así que hagamos esto entonces esto va a
ser igual a la derivada de nuestra
función externa que vamos a resaltar con
este color a la derivada de mi función
externa que es esto
esto elevado a la potencia un cuarto
vamos a sacar la derivada de algo que
está a la 14 es decir la derivada de
esto con respecto a la función interior
con respecto a de x y bueno es
simplemente usar la regla de las
potencias voy a traer este un cuarto que
tengo aquí al frente y me va a quedar
uno
cuarto que multiplica algo ahorita vamos
a ver a que algo elevado a la potencia
un cuarto un cuarto menos uno lo único
que estoy haciendo es la regla de la
potencia pero aquí adentro no tenía una
equis tenía la función de x estoy
sacando la derivada con respecto a de x
con respecto a esta expresión polinómica
así que déjame ponerlo aquí adentro voy
a tener a x cúbica más 4 x cuadrada am
+ 7 y luego quiero multiplicar todo esto
por la derivada del interior con
respecto aa x ojo esto es simplemente
aplicar la regla de la cadena estoy
sacando la derivada del exterior con
respecto a la función interior y después
hay que multiplicarlo por la derivada de
la función interior entonces cuál va a
ser la derivada de de x de de x con
respecto a x bueno lo podemos escribir
aquí
prima de x
va a ser igual y observa es simplemente
aplicar la regla de la potencia varias
veces este 3 lo vamos a bajar y me va a
quedar 3x elevado a la 3 -1 lo cual es
elevarlo al cuadrado más y ahora este 2
lo voy a pasar multiplicando para que
adelante y me va a quedar 8 x elevado a
la potencia 2 - 1 lo cual es la potencia
1 así que podemos no ponerlo y ya está
porque la derivada de 7 con respecto a x
es 0 se eliminan entonces esto de aquí
lo voy a multiplicar por la derivada de
eeuu con respecto a x que es esto que
tenemos aquí que multiplica a 3x
cuadrada más 8
y bueno tal vez esto se pueda limpiar un
poco porque un cuarto esto menos 1 es
exactamente lo mismo que menos tres
cuartos así que lo voy a poner así
tenemos a esto elevado a la menos tres
cuartos y ya está podríamos tratar de
simplificar esto un poco pero lo
importante es que te des cuenta de que
acabamos de hacer la regla de la cadena
eso es la clave bueno la primera cosa
que hicimos fue reconocer que la raíz
cuarta era exactamente lo mismo que
tener esta expresión elevada a la
potencia un cuarto esto es una propiedad
básica de los exponentes y luego
reconocer que aquí tenemos una función
compuesta y como tenemos una función
compuesta entonces al sacar la derivada
lo que hacemos es primero sacar la
derivada de lo exterior con respecto al
interior la derivada del exterior con
respecto al interior y después
multiplicarlo por la derivada del
interior con respecto
muy bien así que si yo les dijera tengo
la función no sé f de x es igual a la
raíz cuarta de x cúbica más 4 x cuadrada
más 7 y te pregunto cuánto vale
efe prima de menos 3 bueno ya que
tenemos la derivada de esta función que
es todo esto de aquí vamos a evaluarlo
en menos tres para ver que obtenemos así
que permítame hacer eso me va a quedar
un cuarto un cuarto que multiplica y
después acá adentro me quedaría menos 3
al cubo es menos 27
+ 4 x 9 esos 36 más 7 esperemos que eso
funcione bien esto elevado a la potencia
menos tres cuartos
veamos si funciona espera menos 27 más 7
es menos 20 más 36
esto se simplifican a 16 muy bien esto
va a ser bastante bueno para elevar de
la potencia menos tres cuartos y después
a eso hay que multiplicarlo por bueno 3
que multiplica 9 esos 27 menos 8 por 3
es 24 y esto también se simplifica
27 - 24 estrés así que vamos a
simplificar un poco esto 3 por un cuarto
eso es lo mismo que
cuartos y después tengo a 16 y en lugar
de poner todo esto primero lo voy a
elevar a la potencia un cuarto y después
lo voy a elevar a la potencia menos 3
estoy haciendo propiedades básicas los
exponentes y ahora 16 elevado a un
cuarto esto de aquí se simplifica a
todos y todos bueno 2 elevado al cubo es
8 entonces 2 elevado a la menos 3 será
un octavo entonces esto es lo mismo que
tres cuartos
8º y esto es igual a 330 y 12 años así
que ya está la pendiente de la recta
tangente a la gráfica
efe de x cuando x es igual a menos 3 es
de 330 y 12 años